right good job guys good job but I'm
gonna have to ask you all one last time
respect the drill okay fire safety is no
laughing matter
I can tell you all pretty gruesome
Charlie do I have to do this now I
switch what you do you make us do this
dumb drill every month and every month
there's no fire hopefully a fire doesn't
break out okay
and that's why we have to respect the
drill Piper what are you doing well I
make one every morning just in case
smart it's the middle of the workday
we're outside this is international
waters your rules don't apply here
is that true Charlie I really need to
get back to work
kaylynn put your shirt back on Harper
stop drinking guys please respect the
drill okay all right that's illegal Anna
Anna come back here you need to imagine
that this building is of flamin tender
box of death great now I have to start I
have to start the time we're all over so
in international waters I can do
whatever I want
oh no no you're thinking of diplomatic
immunity right like it leaves a weapon -
yeah how are we only getting worse I
think so you're saying if I die in
international waters I die in real life
no I would never say that that makes no
sense okay if we don't get Wi-Fi out
here I'm going back inside an imaginary
fire or no guys please respect the drill
we wrap this up kaylynn thinks he's on
vacation I'm afraid he's gonna take his
pants off that's it no you know you guys
think this is all fun and games don't
you
huh well well if you're not gonna
respect me then respect the drill wait
you think we don't respect you so this
is about I don't know I just sometimes I
feel like you guys don't care about what
I do here sorry Charlie
yep we didn't know how important this
was to you
we really appreciate you looking out for
us yeah we uh we were expecting you're
very important to me as an employee
thanks guys hmm I guess I got a little
too worked up about a silly fire drill
huh
you guys know to leave the building when
the alarm goes off right
I guess I just thought it was like
because there are no laws that men of
like physics and biology and math
whether you can just add whatever
numbers you wanted
I just wouldn't matter No
you